we have some breaking news coming in
here in the german capital a car
has been seen crashing into the gate of
german chancellor angela merkel's office
complex just a short distance
from our studios you're looking at
pictures there where there have been
no reports of casualties police say that
they have taken the driver into custody
now merkel was scheduled today to host a
video conference with 16 state leaders
to discuss an extension
of the corona virus lockdown
and for more information on that let's
bring in dw's political correspondent
yulia saudelli
who is standing by for us at the scene
and yulia
what have you been observing there
so uh what um the accident or the event
happened right here behind me where
there is a side entrance to
the chancellery where the press also
usually goes in for events
and you can see here to my side there is
a car
and it has some writing on it some
sentences on the other side
there's a sentence saying uh you damned
killers of children and old people and
on this side it says
against the globalized politics
so police are not saying whether it was
an accident or intentional
although with what is written on the car
is already an indication of what might
could have been the
motive or what could have driven uh the
driver to crash into the gate the car is
only lightly damaged in the front
uh we have strong police presence here
uh we had
an ambulance present and as
you said police has taken the person
into custody and police here have told
us he is being also medically
the person is being medically uh treated
okay well it sounds like somebody who
had a political message there um again
this car crashing into the gate at the
chancellor edw's julia saldelli
we know that you will have any updates
for us
if they indeed develop we appreciate it
you